as guys my name is adjourn or welcome
back to my safe lost love series so
today we're going to be talking about
control flow statements and really this
is going to be a continuation of last
week's episode so if you haven't seen
that episode about loop definitely check
that out they'll be a link in the
description below control flow
statements work with loop so in other
words they kind of give us a little bit
more control as to how these loops
actually run we've kind of got three
main control flow statements that we can
use continues break and return and they
do different things continue can only be
used inside a loop and basically
continue says go to the next iteration
of this loop if there is one otherwise
it'll just end loop break is primarily
used in loops however it also appears in
switch statements and basically breaks
just says get out of the loop the end to
loop and finally return is probably the
most powerful one if you want to
consider it that way because return will
just get out of your function entirely
so if you're in a function and you hit a
return keyword you will exit the
function of course the functions which
actually need to return a value when you
type in return you're conscious have
returned by itself return by itself is
only for void functions if your function
needs to return a value when you type in
return you need to supply it with a
value all right not much else to say
really let's just jump in and take a
look at some examples so this is the
program that we had in the last episode
please give that a run you'll see we
have hello world printing a bunch of
times and then of course we had a bit of
a while loop which Daphnia do-while loop
it does nothing I'll just get rid of
some of these because we don't really
need them the only one that I'll keep
from our previous program is pretty much
that for loop so the first control flow
statement that we'll look at is continue
continue we'll skip to the next
iteration of the for loop
so if I write continue over here just
like this it will actually not impact
the behavior of the for loop at all
because that is already the end of the
for loop when it is that line is going
to continue to the next iteration anyway
that this doesn't modify the behavior at
all however if I do something like if I
mod 2 equals 0 and then have a continue
there and run my program you'll see the
basically what's happening is it's
skipping every second iteration starting
with the first one so a better way to
illustrate this is probably to include
some kind of values but instead of just
logging hello world we can also log the
actual
I variable to see what index is
currently at and if I write that and I
hit f5 you can see that our hello world
segment
only runs with odd iterations in other
words when I is zero it's not going to
run because of course 0 mod 0 PS 0 so
it's going to continue because it's
daemon it's true otherwise when I is 1
we're going to get log when I to we're
not and when is 3 we are and then when I
saw we're not and then of course I never
hits 5 figures when it hits 5 we do not
do the for loops because this statement
says that I must be less than clients
we've also changed this to something a
bit more simple such as if I is greater
than to continue so basically what
should happen here is when I is 0 and I
is 1 and I is true it should print out
our log as well as what I is
however when I is 3 or 4 it shouldn't so
if we run that you'll see we get hello
well printing 3 times great so that's
pretty much it to continue I mean all
it's going to do is when continue gets
hit it will give to the next iteration
the for loop if we actually debug this
by putting a breakpoint here this will
give you some more insights so you can
see here I is 0 which of course is not
going to trigger this so it's going to
go down to log and log and everything
will be fine
same for when I is 1 and I 2 however as
soon as I see s 3 + 3 is greater than 2
we're going to go to continue which
means that if I hit f10 right now
instead of moving down to the blog you
can see it actually jumps back up to the
start of the follows and it will it will
do I plus plus and it will evaluate our
condition and then jump back here and of
course in this case it's going to be the
exact same behavior all right class I
think that's continued sorted let's take
a little break so if I just replace this
code would break it's going to appear to
act the same way you can see that we get
0 1 2 and we don't get anything else
however if I go back to my first example
of if I'm on 2 equals 0 and hit f5 you
can see we actually get absolutely
nothing printing now perhaps a little
bit of a better example here is to
actually print the first value so I'll
just do I plus 1 more 2 equals 0 if we
quickly replaces would continue to just
so you can see what's happening here you
can see that instead of going
odd numbers now it's going even number
so we get 0 2 in for printing so if I
replace this now with break what's
actually going to happen is
it's just going to print that first one
because as soon as it hits that break
statement that said that Luke is over
game over for that loop if we place a
breakpoint over here and we hit f5
you'll see the first time of course
their statements not going to be true so
we don't break but then the second time
we run through this for loop and this is
true when we hit break guess what if I
hit a turn right now we jump straight
out of the for loop into the next line
of code that's a trace break our follows
completely and of course these kind of
control flow statements inside loops
apply to all loops so for loops while
loops do while loops they work the same
in all loops all right and the final one
we have is return now this is a function
that has to return an integer so we
can't just type in return we have to
return something we try and do something
like this and we here controller seven
it's going to fail because you can see
is telling us that main function must
return a value because the declaration
states it has certain initiative so I
could do something like return 0 to 0 of
course is a valid integer and if I run
this code it's actually going to
immediately appear to close our program
because of course we never get to the
STD see in dogs get statement which is
the statement that keeps our window open
because it's expecting us to provide
input so if I again put a breakpoint
here and run my program you'll see the
first time it's fine it'll log hello
world and we do actually get that hollow
world logging up here then a second time
when I hit return 0 that's it look at
that it jumps right to that end curly
bracket because this function is over
now one other thing to note with the
return statement is that you don't have
to use return inside a loop the same way
that you have to with continue and break
returns can be written anywhere so I
could do something like if v is greater
than 8 return zero and of course I have
to provide a value in this case because
this function returns an integer so
return not necessarily inside a loop can
be absolutely anywhere in your code you
also don't even have to have an if
statement you could have something like
this but of course in this case there is
no circumstance under which this line
would get triggered so it is actually
known as Det code and some compilers
especially in other languages will
actually restrict you from writing code
like this because I mean at this point
you might as well just delete this line
it's never going to get called so that's
pretty much it as far as control flow
statements go
turn can be used anywhere and it would
basically just exit the function
remember of course if your function has
to return a value then return has to
give it a value to return these control
flow statements basically form the basis
of how how your flow goes the pad with
loops and if statements and like all of
these control flow statements that is
essentially the logic of programming
those are the tools you have access to
to control the flow of your program
basically which line gets executed next
right those tools if Salmons and
conditionals like that loops and control
flow statements that is it that is the
only thing that can modify the behavior
of your program short from you actually
writing into the instruction pointer
don't do that maybe as in series
progresses and we start actually writing
applications I'll be referencing all of
these control flow statements all the
time and show you examples of where
they're used and how I can use them as
well as probably showing you examples
about how I can write the same code but
without using them or we're using a
different statement so if you want some
more concrete examples of how to
actually work just stay tuned to this
series and in future episodes when we
actually start writing stuff we're
definitely going to cover this because
again this is one of the fundamental
building blocks of writing an
application but anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed this episode if you did please
hit that like button and follow me on
Twitter and Instagram link in the
description below if you really enjoyed
this video and you want to show your
support and make sure that more of these
awesome videos get made you can support
me on patreon icon 4/2 Cherno again link
will be in the description below next
time hope i've got quite the episode for
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you